this year's Oscars made history on the
one hand with its moderate viewing
figures and on the other hand with
parricide winning an Oscar in the
category best film for the first time as
a non-english speaking film but not only
that parasite also won the most Oscars
overall including the categories Best
Director and Best Screenplay in second
place is the war drama 1917 which was
awarded three gold statues the category
Best leading Actor was won by jock in
Phoenix Quentin Tarantino's Once Upon a
Time in Hollywood on the other hand
could only celebrate two awards there is
currently no specific date for the 2021
Oscar Awards but it will most likely
take place again between February and
March Netflix has been working on a
series for the horror video game series
Resident Evil for quite some time
however specific details have been
withheld so far this changed a few days
ago when Netflix accidentally published
the description of the series which was
deleted shortly afterwards but of course
resourceful fans can still access the
description after all the internet never
forgets it's not really detailed but it
gives us a rough idea of the story it
says the town of Clearfield Maryland has
long stood in the shadow of three
seemingly unrelated behemoths the
Umbrella Corporation the decommissions
Greenwood Asylum and Washington DC today
26 years after the discovery of the
t-virus secrets held by the three will
start to be revealed at the first signs
of outbreak so if you believe this
description the Resident Evil series
will be about a completely new plot
besides the well known umbrella
corporation there are supposed to be two
more black sheep the release date of the
series is unfortunately not yet known
already in 2008 a film adaptation of the
classic board game Clue ido was
announced this is supposed to be based
on the cult film clue the movie from
1985 as it is often the case the
production of clue ADA was pushed
further and further back for years until
star actor Ryan Reynolds and his
colleague Jason Bateman
finally wrote a script at the end of
2019 and left the direction to the
letter S variety now reports this is not
going to happen as Bateman is still
committed to the serious Ozark a
suitable replacement could be found soon
because according to information from
variety Alice in Wonderland to director
James Robin is currently in discussion
for the job the plot of Chloe doe
revolves around six people unknown to
each other who meet in a remote house
for a party it happens as it has to as
suddenly one of them dies little by
little the secrets of the guests come to
light and the search for the killer
begins
unfortunately there's no information
about a possible release date at the
moment after Aladdin was very successful
in cinemas around the world last year
it's no wonder that a sequel would not
be long and coming as variety now
reports allotting 2 will be released but
will not consider the fan request for a
remake of Japan's return it is said that
authors John Gatins
and Andrea belif have been working on
the sequel for the past six month but
the plot will have nothing to do with
Jafar's return from 1994 it is believed
that the second part will be more about
just mean and Jeannie played by Anna
ohmy Scott and Will Smith nevertheless
it's not 100% clear at this point of
time if the cast of the first part will
fully return of course we will keep you
up-to-date with more news about the
production of Aladdin - a few days ago
Sony announced the start date of a still
nameless Marvel film on October 8 2021
but it is not yet officially known which
film it is in the past Kraven the hunter
Madame web silk and also black cat and
silver sable were considered furthermore
a comeback of the sinister six still
seems to be in the works the majority of
the fence on the net suspect a Spider
Woman part with Jessica drew the year
2021
seems to be quite packed anyway while
Marvel has 5 movies in the pipeline with
Zhang Jie dr. strange - Thor and
spider-man 3 and yet unknown Marvel Sony
movie DC has three titles planned with a
long awaited the Batman Black Adam and
the Suicide Squad so far 2021 seems to
be a dream year for superhero fans and
who knows what surprise
Marvel and EC still have in store for us
[Music]